foreign
Jamie is in Washington state hi Jamie
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Ken and Dave my question is is my
husband and I are expecting to receive
over a million dollars in a buyout
situation and we're not sure what we
should do if we should take it in one
month
[Laughter]
I wish but I'm not that type I'm kidding
I just couldn't resist I sure wish we
could do I think I think I'll find
something okay wow what happened
something was he hurt or something what
happened
um no we were my husband was involved he
had a partnership in a business and they
decided to buy him out oh cool that's
awesome
okay so you got a million bucks and
you're trying to decide what to do with
that
correct and we owe a 390 on our mortgage
and that's our only debt okay and our
nest egg is 225 around that okay well
then we got 600 left because we just
paid off the house
okay now what are we going to do how old
is he
um he's 41. awesome what's he gonna do
now
we don't we don't know the we kind of
feel like the
options are open
um infinite yeah I got 600k to play with
yeah let's go do something
we're not interested in maybe staying in
Washington so but interest rates were
concerned to move
yeah well you don't have an interest
rate if you have a paid for house
my interest rate's zero because I don't
have one
correct and yours is too now so what's
your house so where are you moving
um we would like to go back to Idaho
where we're from well you can buy a
house for cash in Idaho they'll let you
do that
okay sell the house you got sell the
house you got put some cash with him buy
you a house for cash in Idaho now what's
he you don't know what he's gonna do for
a living yet
yeah no not yet okay all right what
should we take it in one lump sum or
yeah sure about taxes they don't want
him around I'd get I'd get my money away
from them
okay they might they might screw this
thing up and not be able to pay him
later
correct yeah
okay whoa I just hit a nerve yeah
correct
[Music]
yeah yeah get your money now yeah you're
gonna have a little tax on it but oh
well
such happens when somebody gives you a
million dollars but not gives you but
you earned a million dollars and yeah
pay your pay cash for the house and step
one step two is develop a game plan
because he does need something to go to
not just from yeah yeah this is not his
defining moment it's his first it's the
First Act what's he gonna do in the
second act on the third act in The
Encore when he comes back out on stage
and the Applause continues I'd like to
give him a gift Dave I'd love to give
him the get clear assessment along with
from paycheck to purpose as he figures
out the path forward this is a great
time for him to go what do I do best
what do I love to do what results do I
want to put in the world he now has the
freedom to do that yes like a whiteboard
not quite pork you can do anything you
want to and you got the money to go do
it this is very cool it's a great time
Jamie I know it's sad for y'all in a lot
of ways but you really ought to just be
smiling